gare de munich en allemagne
jour après jour train après train les
migrants continuent d'y affluer
trente mille personnes en quelques jours
à peine plus de 200 policiers et
presqu'autant pompiers se relaient 24
heures sur 24 pour diriger le flou tant
bien que mal
chaque jour est un défi un problème
c'est que tout le monde arrive à munich
ça fait beaucoup pour une ville dit le
porte parole de la police les autorités
font le maximum pour répartir les
arrivants à travers le pays des centres
d'accueil et d'hébergement ont été
aménagés dans des centres sportifs des
halles d'exposition ou comme ici dans
une ancienne caserne de l'armée
abdel rahmane street
un étudiant syrien y habite depuis une
semaine et donc non je ne sais pas quand
je pouvoir sortir d'ici ni pour aller où
tout le monde me dit nathan est ce qu'on
va rester sept ou huit mois on ne sait
pas ce contenu le traitement des
demandes d'asile en allemagne prend
habituellement plus d'un an et avec
l'afflux soudain de migrants beaucoup
craignent de voir les délais s'allongent
et un problème particulièrement aigu en
bavière où les lois d'immigration oblige
les demandeurs d'asile à demeurer dans
des camps temps que leur dossier n'est
pas acceptée rachat castus f est en
allemagne depuis presque trois mois
mais ce n'est pas aussi facile que je ne
pensais il ya beaucoup de paperasse et
bureaucratie et la langue d'un problème
dit elle car personne n'hésite pas
anglais pourtant rachat ne veut pas se
plaindre car il se sait privilégié en
tant que syrienne déjà reconnus comme
réfugiés par l'onu sont d'aussi va être
traitée de façon prioritaire
une situation exceptionnelle chez les
demandeurs d'asile il ya des gens
coincés dans des camps depuis cinq ans
sans pouvoir travailler ni même pouvoir
suivre des vrais cours d'allemand ans
dit elle
ce rachat a aussi la chance d'être
hébergés au grand hôtel cosmopolis
plutôt que dans un grand camp sans âme
cette petite auberge communautaire qui
accueille une soixantaine de demandeurs
d'asile est unique en allemagne
l'objectif de son fondateur faire tomber
les murs entre les communautés et
faciliter l'intégration des réfugiés
oui ou non une personne est isolée
pendant cinq ans dans un camp de
réfugiés
son travail coupés des vies sociales et
culturelles que l'avenir du downtown une
chose en tout cas est certaine à moins
d'une solution au problème irakien et
syrien à moins d'une meilleure
répartition européenne des réfugiés la
situation en allemagne n'est pas près de
s'améliorer car le flot de migrants lui
est loin de se tarir les autorités
allemandes s'attendent en effet
maintenant recevoir plus d'un demi
million chaque année ici jean françois
bélanger radio-canada munich